jetzt kommen wir aber zu einer demo auf
einer autobahn und zwar auf der autobahn
1 bei hamburg in höhe der nordbrücke ist
es an diesem morgen zu einer
unangemeldeten demonstration gekommen
rund 200 personen haben die wichtige
straße für viele berufspendler blockiert
der grund sie wollten mit dieser
tatsächlich lebensgefährlichen aktion
auf die situation in der kaukasusregion
berg karabach aufmerksam machen
fahrzeuge menschen standen bis vor
wenigen minuten dort auf der fahrbahn
jetzt hat sich mittlerweile dem und
demonstration aufgelöst bis dahin war
aber in beide richtungen zwischen dem
maschener kreuz um moorfleet die
autobahn gesperrt ja und darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit meinem kollegen
thomas knoop der bei dieser aktion auch
vor ort war
wie läuft es denn jetzt gerade rollt er
wieder jetzt wo die demonstration
aufgelöst ist da die autobahn ist
ballsicher zeit gegeben worden
jetzt haben aber links feuer zu
erheblichen staus muss heute morgen
brach top ten in hamburg hatte
auswirkungen bis in die stadt
ich selber hatte auf der anfahrt
erhebliches problem überhaupt zu kommen
eine solche aktion mitten auf der
autobahn sind lebensgefährlich für die
demonstranten und für die vielen
berufspendler ist irgendwas passiert
passiert ist zum glück nichts aber das
ganze seiner tat hochgefährlich die
demonstranten mit ihren autos direkt auf
der autobahn gehalten und sind dann
ausgestiegen
durch den rückstau jetzt auch unfälle
geben können wer die polizei auf diese
unangemeldete aktionen reagiert die
polizei war von der aktion die über
soziale netzwerk in verabredet wurde
zunächst überrascht hat dann sehr starke
kräfte zusammengezogen
der polizeihubschrauber waren dann oft
auf der elbe war dass du die feuerwehr
wurden bereitgestellt
ja am ende wie gesagt nach mehr als zwei
stunden hat das wir sehen der verkehr
rollt wieder vielen dank thomas knoop
für diese einblicke von der a1
dankeschön
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren